un accord à l'amiable et une première
victoire pour la famille de georges
floyd la ville de minneapolis lui
versera 27 millions de dollars de
dommages et intérêts le paiement l'un
des plus importants concernant des faits
reprochés à la police a été approuvé
vendredi par un vote unanime du conseil
municipal nous savons qu aucune somme
d'argent ne pourra effacer la douleur et
le traumatisme intense causée par la
mort de john lloyd à sa famille et à
plan de personnes au sein de notre
communauté
mennea presse à minneapolis a été changé
en profondeur par cette époque où le
racisme a été prise en compte en juin
2020 la famille de john floyd avait
déposé plainte au civil contre la ville
et les quatre policiers impliqués dans
sa mort une partie de la somme versée
par la ville sera dévolu à l'aménagement
du quartier ou l'afro américain est mort
devenu le point de ralliement des
manifestations en sa mémoire
un accord à l'amiable donc mais aussi
une entente sur la nécessité de revoir
en profondeur le système de justice
sociale la décision n'est pas seulement
historique en raison des 27 millions de
dollars versés mais aussi pour son
impact sur la réforme de la politique de
justice sociale et de la police le neveu
de georges floyd brandon williams a lui
estimé que l'accord représentait un pas
nécessaire pour permettre à la famille
de faire son deuil
vous savez nous avons tous dû regarder
cette vidéo atroce c'est douloureux ça
fait mal mais aujourd'hui vous savez
c'est une étape énorme dans le processus
de guérison
je ne parle pas uniquement de la douleur
que ressent notre famille j'espère qu'il
s'agit aussi d'une guérison s'agissant
des méthodes de la police
excluant au delà du règlement monétaire
c'est l'espoir d'un changement majeur de
politique raciale mais la lutte pour la
famille de georges floyd n'est pas fini
le procès au pénal de derek chauvine le
policier accusé de l'avoir asphyxié avec
son genou en l'immobilisant à terre
s'est ouvert ce mardi et la famille
semble moins optimiste en raison d'une
justice pénale que l'on a déjà vu assez
discriminatoire à l'égard des afro
américains